Đói chào, tên mình không nên tự mình đặt vào cái bãi.
Và quá hăng lâu lắng về giúp dò,
về chí phi rồi, có thể mình lâu lắng là liệu làm,
nó có tự sự nếu quái không?
Vì không giắn là.
Hãy về nên cái tập lý là không giắn là em,
và nếu mà mình không làm tự lạc,
nếu mà mình không có về sự mắt đầu thì không giấm đi,
có có dợi mình đi đến,
thì mình đừng, đừng, đừng, đừng,
tất cả cái tư dùi,
để mai sẽ phụ mình đừng,
bị quá à gó, thì chúng ta sẽ tự 2 nữa là mình đến,
soi cái xuyên nghiệm mình là,
giữa cái câu chẹt,
trên ở số và cái câu chẹt chí phi.
Thì đừng ý nó là những cái mốt thận,
đừng ý nó là những cái nó không, nó,
đối rất, mạng ý theo hướng là nó là 2 cái nó,
tương xin, nó, có trở ở tu nhau,
bởi vì sao, bởi vì nếu mà anh làm đúng,
làm tốt được cái việc trên ở số.
Đi cái, tương lai nó mang lại nó những cái nó,
việc quá, những cái mề tối với chi phí,
những cái nó mang lại nó trời.